Speaker 1: Well, truth social is very rapidly
heading towards bankruptcy. And I actually do
like this, but not because I necessarily want
to see it fail, but because it does confirm
that the demand that the right claims is there for
some completely unfettered free speech platform,
for the right to be allowed to say what they want
really isn't there. There really isn't the demand
for it. So let's back up a little bit. Truth
social is this right wing social media platform.
It's Donald Trump's social media platform to
some degree. And the idea of truth social was
all of the conservative voices being censored on
Twitter and elsewhere. You're going to be able
to go to truth social and you will be free to say
whatever you want. Everyone can say whatever they
want on truth social. Turns out number one wasn't
actually the case. Lots of people getting banned
on truth social for talking about the January six
committee hearings or for all bunch of different
things. So it turns out it wasn't really this free
speech platform they claim it would be. Secondly,
turns out it wasn't really a platform too many
people were interested in. And the latest sort
of nail in the coffin is that investors are
pulling almost $140 million from the company that
is planning to merge with Trump's truth social.
The Businessinsider article writes The deadline
for Digital World to acquire Trump's Truth Social
Past on September 20th, investors are walking away
from planned commitments of $140 million. Reuters
reports that savvy management investors bowed out,
taking away $100 million. This is going to likely
be the demise of truth, social and of course,
as far as these investors go, the fact that they
were going to invest in the first place shows
that they're not necessarily the most brilliant
investors. Many of the businesses that Trump is
a part of end up going under and investors lose
money. Trump tries to run away with the cash, and
it's a complete and total disaster. But I think
the most important, the reason I love this is
that they love to say the entire right. And, you
know, they sometimes they'll claim the right is
225 million people. Trump recently said 75 million
people voted for him and that there's probably
another 150 million Trumpists as well. The numbers
don't even make sense. Absurd numbers if you look
at how many adults there are in the US makes no
sense whatsoever. But their story is there's tens
of millions or hundreds of millions of us. We are
being silenced on Twitter and everywhere else, and
we really want a platform where we can say what
we want and say what we believe. And it's going
to be great and it's going to be profitable and
it's going to explode. They create truth, social,
and it just kind of goes nowhere. And what I love
is that truth social is failing in the marketplace
of ideas. Nobody's censoring truth social.
Nobody's shutting it down. But slowly but surely,
people don't care. They don't really have users.
And it just declines and declines and declines.
And it looks like ultimately it's going to end
up going under completely. It will, of course,
be blamed on radical leftists, globalists,
whatever. But the reason it's failing is
because it's terrible and it's even sort of like
a Twitter clone. If you look at the platform,
the buttons, the read, the re truth and all the
entire design and user interface, it's basically
a Twitter clone. And so if your belief is Twitter
on a technical level is fine, but it needs to be
free from censorship of conservatives, then by
definition, truth social should be doing really
well. It's not it's not doing well and it's
going to go under. And I absolutely love it.